this does seem to get
vicinity of things like what are our
moral responsibilities to people are at
the bottom of the ladder so the way
meaning is associated with helping
people who have no feel as if they have
no communal resources whatsoever I mean
there's there are two kinds we're doing
a series of experiments now all over the
world and it might seem that the this
experiment has no parents have no
obvious connection to flourishing but in
fact we're just having people the key
point of the experiment is simplicity
the people are merely making laudry
choices lots of them and they're playing
out the lotteries right make your choice
in this lottery in that lourd they do
forty or sixty of them and we pay them
[Music]
yeah so well well we covered the
so-called marsac machine a triangle to
mix it allows us to ask to make the
curvature of their utility functions the
interesting point is this there's two
societies we've done this we've done
these lottery choices and we're not
doing them for this reason we've got
other reasons why we do that but we've
done these lottery choices in Ethiopia
in East Timor in no no we barely pay
them in lots actually we pay them well
so very sadly prices we we've done them
in India and East Timor and Uganda and
Ethiopia and Ghana and and of course in
America we've done a third of the adult
population of Denmark the there's two
societies South Africa and did not South
African middle class people so every can
poor people and Guatemala where people
will deliver systematically particularly
women and we didn't know it's only the
last two current we realized it's being
driven by the women they will
systematically choose smaller prizes
over larger ones right we could write a
paper called South African poor women
don't like money right now we're the
reason seems to be and we're busy trying
to tease the losers
these lotteries will have the same total
as payoff but just a lot of small prizes
versus a few big ones or is the total
payoff different in the tools the
expected path so there's many lotteries
and we vary the we vary the
relationships between the lotteries
generally speaking the so called be luck
we have an A Series and a B series and
in general the B Series are have higher
variance in the prizes so they're
riskier but but but sometimes the B
lotteries have higher higher expected
values than the a lotteries and partly -
as a test to make sure that people
understand what they're doing we always
make sure we give them at least one
choice at least one choice where the B
lottery is both less risky and has a
higher payoff so if you choose the a
lottery in that case you're choosing
less money over more right you're
preferring a smaller prize only in south
and we use it again and we use it to
test just to make sure that that people
understand what they're doing only in
South Africa and Guatemala do people
choose that too substantial numbers of
people and it's mostly women choose that
a prize in the tombola dominant
dominated case in the case where the B
lotteries less risky and has a higher
payout and what it seems to be about is
such terror of other people they don't
want money they'd rather have less money
because they're because they're very
very scared they are afraid that if they
have the money it will be will be beaten
up no I think I think it's more
existential I mean that's what I mean I
want that part I don't understand that
link that's part of it so so I mean yes
they're afraid if they're afraid that
they'll be that it'll don't actually be
mugged they're also afraid of the that
lots of social pressure they'll attract
the attention of other people and they
don't want the - tension of other people
because most other people in their
environment are dangerous but then also
I think we're now doing a series of
experiments in which people play games
that have mixed strategy equilibria and
they're playing another game set of
games that have a pure strategy
equilibrium
and the payoff expected payoff is higher
in the fear strategy case and they get
to choose which game to play so now
we're see because we were also have this
hypothesis that if you're terrified
enough of your social environment you
might actually project your you might
start thinking of the environment at the
universe itself as malignant and you
might actually play mixed strategies
against nature like you want to hide
your utility function right you don't
want if you think nature is actually man
bear in mind in sub-saharan Africa many
people don't believe there are such
things as chance events they'll get
quite angry if you tell them right that
it rolling of a dice or flipping a coin
is a chance event right so they think
which cross they think yeah they think
their ancestors they think their
ancestry control stuff so is there a
sense when they when they want less
money is there any part of it which is
that they don't deserve that money or
they shouldn't have it um there's a
really just fear that's a good yeah we
haven't looked at that that's a good
idea we haven't we haven't looked at you
know economists are not very good at
finding subjects objective latent States
right it's not our not everything really
so we haven't we haven't looked at that
so I can't comment
we certainly do ask them questions about
their levels of trust in others and and
the the it's a South African and what
they're never gonna call them all in
women go off the charts on on those
those objective distress questions if
the social yeah it's so terrifying just
so that you know this thing that I have
sort of
mana that we all want to matter in
exactly inverses you don't want a matter
you just want to disappear
you